بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول تعالى
يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم
عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم خبير
سبق الكلام على جل ما في هذه الايه
من عبر لنا
وبقي علينا
قوله تعالى ان الله عليم خبير
قوله تعالى ان الله عليم
عليم
على وزن فعيل
وهذا الوزن مبالغه في اسم الفاعل من العلم
يقال
عالم
وعليم يرحمك الله عالم
وعليم
بمعنى راحم ورحيم
وما شابه ذلك فهو اسم فاعل
مسوغ على وزن فعيل للدلاله على المبالغه
في العلم
هذه
المبالغه
وهذا العلم الذي هو علم الله سبحانه
وتعالى فانه شامل
يعلم الله سبحانه وتعالى ما كان
وما
وكائن
وما لو كان كيف يكون
ويعلم كل شيء من المخلوق وغير المخلوق ومن
الممكنات والواجبات والممتنعات وما شابه
ذلك
وهذا العلم
فانه غير مسبوق
بجاهل
خلافا لعلوم الخلق
ولذلك لا يطلق على الله سبحانه وتعالى
العارف
او
ما هو مشتق من المعرفه عرف يعرف
عرف يعرف
عفوا
فعرفه والمعرفه لا يصرف يوصف الله سبحانه
وتعالى
بها الا
اخبارا او الا في المقابله
جاء في حديث في السنن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم راى
كبشين
متناطحين
فسال احد الصحابه اتدري فيما ينتطحان
قال الله ورسوله اعلم قال
الله يعرف
في روايه قال لا
اعرف قال الله يعرف
او الله يعرف
وسيقضي بينهما يوم القيامه على كل حال
المعرفه
او
ما شابه ذلك فان المعرفه في لغه العرب لها
لوازم لا بد منها
ايش معنى هذا الكلام يعني عرف عرفت الشيء
انا عرفت الشيء هذا يدل على انني كنت
جاهلا به سابقا كن جاهل به ثم عرفته وكذلك
مثلا يوصف لك شيء
فتكون الاوصاف عندك ثم ترى هذا الشيء
فتقول عرفته بالاوصاف التي وصفتها لي فهذا
يدل على المشاهده بعد العلم بالاوصاف
والمعرفه لا بد ان يكون
جاهلا صاحبه قبل ان عرف ثم عرف وهذا ممتنع
على الله سبحانه وتعالى الله عز وجل علمه
تام لا يسبقه جهل ولا يلحق نسيان يقول
تعالى
لا يضل ربي ولا ينسى
هذه هي الاسباب وغيرها
مما جعل الله عز وجل لا يصف نفسه بالمعرفه
وانما يصف نفسه بالعلم لكن مثلا لو في درج
الكلام
واحد قال
مثل مثل الاخبار عن الله سبحانه وتعالى
وهو اوسع من الوصف عند العلماء فتقول مثلا
الله يعرف كذا وكذا او عرف الله مني كذا
وكذا او ما شابه ذلك من الاطلاقات هل هذا
صحيح جائز الجواب انه جائز لكن وصف الله
بالمعرفه تقول الله
عارفا او عرافا او ما شابه ذلك او
تسميته بذلك فهذا لا يجوز وانما جاء
الاخبار والاخبار اوسع من الوصف عند
العلماء فالله عز وجل يوصف بالعلم
يوصف بالعلم
يعني اذا انا قلت مثلا
عرفه وعلم ايش الفرق عرف اذا وصفت وقلت
فلان عرف لازم يكون معناه انه جاهله قبل
ذلك ثم عرف
غلاف للعلم علم لا
يستلزم هذا لا يستلزم هذا في لغه العرب
قال تعالى خبير خبير على وزن فعيل
وصفه وهو
وهو
مسوق على وزن فعيل من اسم الفاعل من الخبر
الخبر
وتفاصيل
المعلوم
خفيه
هذا هو الخبر في لغه العرب
يعني الامور
خفيه التي تخفى
على المطلع
فهذه تسمى
بارا
فلذلك
فان كلمه خبر يدل على ما تحت الارض ما تحت
الثرى من النبات او مشابه ذلك لذلك
جاء هذا
اللفظ في القران
في اماكن معينه معينه مثلا يقول تعالى
واتقوا الله ان الله عليم بذات الصدور
ثم في الايه اللي بعدها
واتقوا الله ان الله خبير بما تعملون ايش
ايش السر
يعني في الاولى قال عليم بذات الصدور لانه
عاده الذي
يعتقد شيئا في صدره فانه على ظاهره يعني
اذا اعتقد شيئا فانه يعتقده على ظاهره ولا
يخفي شيئا لانه لا يطلع عليه احد فالله
يعلم ذلك لكن في العمل قال ان الله خبير
بما تعملون لان العامل
قد
يفعل او يعمل الاعمال وفي نيته وفي نيته
اشياء اخرى وفي نيته
ونيته ليست موافقه لعمله
والله عز وجل يقول ان الله خبير بما
تعملون يعني خبير سبحانه وتعالى ويعلم
الخافي من
الضمائر
والاعمال ما ظهر منها والاعمال التي لا
يعلمها الناس فاذا جمع الله سبحانه وتعالى
بين ان الله عليم خبير فان هذا يدل على
علم تام وهذا يدل على معرفه تامه
بالظواهر والبواطن والحقائق وما شابه ذلك
وهذا جاء بعد قوله تعالى انا اكرمكم عند
الله اتقاكم
اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم
وقد يقول قائل التقوى
تقوى توفيق من الله سبحانه وتعالى
انسان
يؤتيه الله سبحانه وتعالى تقوى
وقد يؤتيه الله سبحانه وتعالى اسبابا
لاكتساب التقوى لا يؤتيها او يتيحها لغيره
نقول ان الله عليم خبير يعني عليم بمن
يحسن به ان يسري هذه الاسباب
لمن وكذلك خبير
بالظواهر والبواطن والمستقبلات وما شابه
ذلك فان الظاهر هو الذي يظهر لنا
ولكن الله سبحانه وتعالى يعلم الظاهر
والباطن قالت الاعراب وامنا قل لم تؤمنوا
ولكن قولوا اسلمنا ولما يدخل الايمان في
قلوبكم
وان تطيعوا الله ورسوله لا يلدكم من
اعمالكم شيئا ان الله غفور رحيم
قالت الاعراب امنا
لاحظوا شيئا معي هنا انه قال قالت الاعراب
قالت
واصل المتوقع ان يقال قال الاعراب
صح ولا لا مذكر
وهذا ياتي كثيرا في القران ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يطلق التانيث على المذكر او العكس
للدلاله على اشياء فمثلا يقول تعالى
كذبت ثمود
كذبت ثمود بطغواها كذب ثمود هذا هو
المتوقع ثمود مذكر لكن الله عز وجل اطلق
عليه بتاء التانيث كذبت ثمود لماذا ليدل
على ضعف حجه
وضعف
تكذيب
ثمود لان العرب
يرون ان الذكر فيه
القوه
وان المؤنث فيه الضعف هذه اصول الاوصاف
فاذا ارادوا ان
يطلقوا او ارادوا ان يشعروا السامع بشيء
من الضعف
يطلقون بالتانيث واذا ارادوا ان
واذا ارادوا ان يصفوا المؤنث بشيء من
القوه الخارجه عن العاده
فانهم يطلقون على التانيث بالمذكر وهكذا
مثل
السماء منفطر به
سماء مذكر ولا مؤنث
مؤنث صح مؤنث لانه مقابل
ومقابلات في لغه عاده مؤنثه الجوارح
جوارح ذات الاثنين وكذلك
المقابلات السماء والارض والليل والنهار
فالسؤال الان
لماذا اطلق على السماء هنا بالتذكير فقال
السماء منفطرا كان المتوقع
منفطره به هذا يدل على
قوه
انفطار ووجل السماء من امر الساعه
خارج العاده فهو اطلق المذكر على المؤنث
للمبالغه
هذا يقع كثيرا في
القران
ويقع كثيرا في لغه العرب لذلك مثلا المراه
الحامل ايش يعني الحامل امراه حامل
يعني هذا الكلام يعني
حبله صح ولا لا
ما بيقولوا حامله
راى حامله قول امراه
حامل
للمبالغه على الحمل فهذا يدل على اعظم حمل
هو من شان المراه وذلك حمل الولد كذلك
العكس مثلا اذا ارادوا ان يصفوا
احدا بالعلم المفرط فانهم يقولون علامه
علامه تانيث صح الاصل علام علام
لكن للمبالغه اذا ارادوا بعد
تصوير
الافعال وتصويق اسماء الفاعل واسماء
المفعول وما شابه ذلك ما زال يريد المتكلم
ان يبالغ
فانه قد يطلق المؤنث على المذكر والمذكر
على المؤنث فيقال علامه
صاحب علم مفرط يعني
فهنا قال
قالت الاعراب امنا
وهذا ايضا ينبغي ان يعرف وذلك ان الجموع
الجموع في لغه العرب كلها مؤنثه الا جمع
مذكر سالم
كل الجموع يجوز عليها التانيث كلها
وجاء في بعض الابيات
هذا المعنى فان
الجمع في لغه العرب مؤنث
يجوز عليه اطلاق التانيث الا الجمع المذكر
السالم لانه مو غربي التذكير فهون يقول
قالت الاعراب جمع
اعرابي وهذا اسم جنس جمعي في لغه العرب
اسم جنس جمعي يفرق بينه وبين مفرده
بالزياده
يعني الاصل
فانا بدي اطلق الزياده
على الكلمه بزيدها صح ولا لا
بزيدها حروف
عياده المبنى تدل على زياده المعنى بس
عندنا كلمه كل ما زدت عليها كل ما نقص
منها
من ذلك
جنس اسم جنس الجمعي
مثل شجره وشجر
بنقص من عدد الحروف بزيد فيه المعنى شجر
جمع شجره واحده
مثل بقر وبقره صح ولا لا ونفس الشيء هنا
اعراب واعرابي هذه ياه النسبه هذه تدل على
الافراد اعرابي واحد واعراب جماعه جمع
هذا
الاطلاق قالت الاعراب امنا
اطلق عليه التانيث واختار التانيث هنا
للدلاله على ضعف
على ضعف هذه المقوله وان هذه المقوله
خاليه من
الاستدلال خاليه من من الدليل دعوه ضعيفه
قالت الاعراب امنا
هذه
الايه ذكر العلماء انها انزلت في بني اسد
لما جاؤوا الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
في عام الوفود
وتفاخروا على
ضعفاء
وفقراء المهاجرين والانصار
وتعاظموا عليهم
بعلو النسب
فانزل الله يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من
ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
وزعموا كذلك انهم امنوا
يعني جاؤوا الى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلمهم
جدد في الاسلام
لكنهم زعموا
انهم وصلوا الغايه في هذه الديانه
ودخلوا دخولا لم يدخله احد من قبلهم
فقال تعالى قالت الاعراب وامنا ولم يقل
بنو اسد
لاسباب من هذه الاسباب
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى اراد ان
يجعل كتابه
ذابه
شاملا لجميع الازمنه جميع الامكنه
وكذلك فانه سبحانه وتعالى اعتنى بالاوصاف
للاسماء في كتابه
انا بالاوصاف
واعتنى به
الالقاب اكثر من الاسماء
وحتى الاسماء التي اختارها الله سبحانه
وتعالى فانها اسمى تدل على معاني
هي اشبه بالاوصاف
مثل جبرائيل وميكائيل وابراهيم واسماعيل
وما شابه ذلك
فيقول تعالى ردا عليهم قالت الاعراب امنا
قل لم تؤمنوا ولكن قولوا اسلمنا هنا فرق
الله بين المعنى الايمان ومعنى الاسلام
وهذان اللفظان في
ثاني الشرع
بمعنى بنفس المعنى
الا اذا جاءت
جاءت هاتان الكلمتان في سياق واحد
هذه الفاظ يقول فيها العلماء هذه الكلمات
اجتمعت افترقت وان افترقت اجتمعت ايش يعني
ان اجتمعت في سياق واحد افترقت في المعنى
واذا افترقت في
سياق فان هذه الكلمات تجتمع في المعنى
فماذا نعني بذلك مثلا في القران
الايمان والعمل الصالح
الايمان والعمل الصالح الا الذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات كثيرا موجوده في القران
واحيانا يطلق الله العمل الصالح وحده هل
يعني هذا ان العمل الصالح وحده دون
الايمان يكفي في دخول الجنه له وانما اذا
ذكر الله الايمان وحده
كان داخل في الايمان العمل الصالح ما في
ايمان صحيح دون عمل صالح وكذلك اذا ذكر
الله العمل الصالح وحده واراد به ايضا
الايمان واذا جاء في نفس السياق امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات فهذه تكون
بمعنى الايمان الذي في القلب
والعمل الصالح ما يكون ظاهرا
وزياده على هذا التصديق كذلك مثل
الفقير والمسك والمسكين
الفقير والمسكين ايش الفرق
اذا جاء الفقير وحده في سياق معناه
المسكين الفقير واذا جاء المسكين وحده في
سياق معناه المسكين والفقير لكن اذا جاء
الفقير والمسكين معا في نفس السياق لا بد
ان يكون في فرق الان
انما الصدقات للفقراء والمساكين طب ايش
الفقير والمسكين الان لا في نفس السياق
المعنى يختلف
فيكون الفقير اشد فقرا اشد
فاقه وحاجه من المسكين المسكين احسن منه
حالا
وانطلق العلماء من هذا
المبدا
يعرفون الفقير والمسكين على اختلاف
مصطلحات العلماء
وقيودهم في ذلك
ومن ذلك ايضا
البر والتقوى البر والتقوى مثلا البر
من
الوسع البر بمعنى الواسع في العمل ومن هذا
البر البر يعني واسع في العمل واسع وفي
الاحسان
منه اسم الله البر البر يعني الواسع في
الفضل والاحسان
والتقوى يكون من ماذا من الوقايه وهو
الاصل الدرع للمكروه
هذا يسمى ايش تقوى
فاذا جاءت التقوى وحدها
هدى للمتقين معناه المتقين والابرار نفس
المعنى
المتقي الذي يقوم بالعمل الصالح وينتهي عن
العمل
المحرم كذلك البر ان الابرار يشربونه
ابرار جمع بار
والبار هو الذي يقوم بالطاعه وينتهي عن
المعصيه لكن اذا جاء
التقوى والبر في نفس السياق
وتعاونوا على البر والتقوى
على البر والتقوى
صار افتراق في المعنى اجتمعت
السياق تفترق فيه المعنى فيصير البر
للاعمال في المطلوبه والخيرات الاعمال
الصالحه والتقوى الانتهاء عن المعصيه
ونفس الشيء الاثم والعدوان
الاثم يكون في فعل ماء يؤثم صاحبه بينه
وبين الله والعدوان ما فيه
ما فيه
تجرؤ على حق الخير وهكذا
هذه
الكلمات كثيره قد افرد فيها
كثير من العلماء بل رسائل وكتبا حرروها في
هذه الكلمه من ذلك ايضا الله والرب
الله الرب
فان الرب
اذا كان وحده فهو المعبود بحق
وهو المالك والله وحده كان
المالك والمعبود بحق واذا قيل الله رب
العالمين صار الله المعبود بحق الرب الذي
رب العالمين ولذلك يطلق الرب ويراد به
المعبود
السؤال منكر ونكير من ربك
ربك مش يعني من الذي خلقك لان الامتحان
ليس في هذا بل من ربك يعني من كنت تعبد
فالرب هنا اطلق واريد به المعبود
هذه كلمات كثيره من هذه الكلمات الايمان
والاسلام
بل والاحسان
بل والدين الدين الدين والايمان بنفس
المعنى
فاذا جاء الدين وحده اريد به
الايمان والاسلام واذا جاء الاسلام وحده
اريد به الايمان والاسلام واذا جاء
الايمان وحده اريد به الايمان والاسلام
لكن ان اجتمعت هذه كلها
كان الاسلام للاعمال الظاهره والايمان
للاعمال
الباطنه
ما تنطوي ينطوي عليه القلب من الاعتقادات
واليقين وكذلك الاحسان
يكون مجملا في ذلك كله
فبنفس السياق
يقول
جبريل عليه السلام يا محمد
بل اخبرني عن الاسلام
قال
ان تشهد ان لا اله الا الله وان محمدا
رسول الله وتقيم الصلاه وتؤتي الزكاه
وتصوم رمضان وتحج البيت
قال اخبرني عن الايمان قال ان تؤمن بالله
وملائكته وكتبه الحديث معروف حديث عمر
وحديث ابي هريره
فجاء الاسلام والايمان في نفس السياق في
نفس المكان في نفس المقام فكان الاسلام
للاعمال الظاهره والايمان للاعمال الباطنه
لكن حينما يقول تعالى مثلا
لا يدخل الجنه الا مؤمن
لن تنالوا البر حتى تؤمنوا ماشي حتى
تؤمنوا هل يعني ذلك حتى يصير ايمان
وما في اعمال صالحه تكون مع الايمان هذا
محال ليس ثم ايمان صحيح دون قسط
اقل واجب من الاسلام
وكذلك الاسلام الاسلام لا يكون صحيحا الا
بقسط من اقل واجب من الايمان
ماشي فهنا
جمع الله
المعنيين في السياق وحده فقال قالت
الاعراب امنا قل لم تؤمنوا ولكن قل
لم تؤمنوا ولكن قولوا اسلمنا ولما يدخل
الايمان في قلوبكم فرق الله بين معنى
الايمان ومعنى الاسلام هنا
فقوله تعالى قل لم تؤمنوا
هذا والله اعلم يدل على انهم كانوا
ضعاف الايمان جدا
بان
الشيء الضعيف الذي لا يكاد يذكر فانه يجوز
نفيه تماما في اللغه مبالغه
مهمه جدا ويكثر سوء الفهم فيها كثيرا
يعني مثلا
نسمع حديث حديث كثيره
ياتي في الحديث يقال
يؤتى بالرجل يوم القيامه لم يعمل خيرا قط
لم يعمل خيرا قط
بعض الناس بعض بعض الطلاب يستشكل هذه كل
يعني ما صلى ما قال لا اله الا الله يعني
مثلا اشهد ان لا اله الا الله مش هذا خير
خير عظيم بل هو اساس الخير
لكن هنا من في هذا لم يعمل خيرا قط
الذين ليس لهم حظ في العلم يقولون شايف مش
واجب الواحد يؤمن ولا حتى ممكن اي واحد
يدخل الجنه
غلط باجماع المسلمين وهذا اي واحد اي فلاح
او امراه في بيتها من المسلمين بيعرفوا
هذا الكلام
لكن هذه مبالغه
في الزياده لم يعمل خيرا قط يعني اتى باقل
الواجب
ليكون مسلما مؤمنا جائز عليه دخول الجنه
ولكنه لم يعمل شيئا يذكر
لم يعمل خيرا قط
ثم يذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم خيرا
فعله
وهنا
نفس الشيء يجوز نفي الشيء
والمراد نفي الكمال او المراد نفي
الصحه او المراد نفي الوجود صح ولا لا
يعني الرجل جاء وسلم على الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم ثم ذهب يصلي ثم عاد عليه فقال
ارجع فصلي فانك لم تصلي هو صلي ولا ما صلى
حسا صلى لكن حكما ما صلى صح ولا لا
حكما ما صلى
فجاز نفي الصلاه كذلك
نحن
يجمع المسلمون على انه من صلى دون شروط
الصلاه فان صلاته
غير صحيحه مثلا واحد ياتي يصلي بدون وضوء
صلاه تامه وحلوه وجميله وفيها اطمئنان
وفيها لكن غير متوضي وغير متيمم ولا عذر
له وذاكر متعمد ذلك صلاته صحيحه هل احد من
المسلمين يقول صلى ما صلى
فلم يفعل الصلاه لم يصلي
فنافي الله سبحانه وتعالى الايمان ليس
معناه انهم انكروا
كون النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم رسولا
هذا كفر هذا ليس ايمانا
لكن المقصود انهم
لم ياتوا
بالايمان التام الذي له ذكر بل ما زالوا
في درجه الاسلام الاسلام اقل درجه من
الايمان اذا كانت مع بعضها
لذلك
كل مؤمن مسلم ولا العكس بهذا الاعتبار وكل
محسن مؤمن ولا العكس وكل محسن مسلم ولا
العكس صح بهذا الاعتبار
يعني اذا قلنا عندنا درجات للدين درجه
الاولى الاسلام والدرجه الثانيه الايمان
والدرجه الثالثه الاحسان
فاننا نقول انه من كان مؤمنا فمن باب اولى
هو مسلم ولا العكس ليس كل مسلم مؤمنا
والعكس صحيح وكذلك من كان محسنا فانه مؤمن
ومسلم دون العكس صح ولا لا فهذا هو المعنى
هنا قالت الاعراب امنا قل لم تؤمنوا
ولكن قولوا اسلمنا ثم علل ذلك وقال ولما
يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم هل هذا يدل على
انهم كانوا كفارا لا يدل على ذلك لان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قبل منهم
ولو كانوا كفارا واطلاعه الله على ذلك لما
جاز له ان يقبل منهم ذلك وانما قبل
واقره الله سبحانه وتعالى على قبوله ولكن
نفى الايمان في مقابل في مقابل الاسلام
بهذا المعنى يعني لم ياتوا بالايمان الذي
هو ايمان كامل
وانما اتوا بشيء من الايمان
وهذا الشيء قليل بالنسبه لما لم ياتوا به
فلا يجوز لهم ان يطلقوا على انفسهم هذا
الاطلاق الذي فيه نوع من التزكيه هذا
ونكمل غدا ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
اي عبد الله